well we the beat is bringing back freak
the beat this Halloween weekend at
Ferguson's downtown the festival will
feature a set by Young Bay who is
actually joining us live right now hi
young Bae how are you
good how are you good we're excited to
have you come out here to Vegas tell us
what we can expect tell us a little bit
about your set that you'll be performing
this weekend
yeah I mean I usually uh tell people I
kind of come from funky Roots I'm really
big on sampling disco house so kind of
expect like a lot of that you know
almost like a little wedding set let's
have some fun with it I love that a
wedding set it always gets everyone up
dancing and let's talk about you just
released a new album tell us a little
bit about that
yeah so I split it into two halves it's
called Groove Continental side a it's
the first half
um and it's kind of my vision of what
Motown or like the 60s and 70s would
kind of look like if it were made today
um and then I'm dropping the second half
of that real soon so I'll be playing a
bunch of tunes from those and you have
some really awesome collab
collaborations on the
Yahoo can you tell us about any of that
yeah uh I mean they're all people on
kind of stanza first and foremost I mean
we got pink sweats on there Sam Fisher
Channel Trace Awolnation slender bodies
just a whole bunch
um and just again all people I'm fans of
so it's really special for me well that
would be really fun for everyone to hear
a little taste of that this coming
weekend and I know costumes are
encouraged obviously it's Halloween
weekend there's going to be drink
specials food a little bit of everything
going on and how excited are you to just
bring it out here I feel like the the
energy in Vegas is always unlike
anywhere else
oh I love it I've only been to Vegas a
handful of times too so I'm always
excited to kind of go back and get into
it I'm like oh my gosh Vegas doesn't
sleep I swear that's right well we are
ready for you out here Ferguson's is
such a fun place so hope you enjoy your
time out here everyone go see young Bae
performing at Ferguson's I got a lot of
fun stuff going on over the weekend Las
Vegas now we'll be right back